when it comes to business I think
everybody thinks that it's the
equivalent of somehow walking across the
plains of Africa and bit different when
you've got to walk 10 miles to the river
and there's hippos and lions and things
actual things that can eat you whereas
like in business you can make mistakes
you call them failures if you want to
but you can use them as opportunities to
learn and there's only two things that
can possibly go wrong you lose a bit of
money or you lose a bit of face so look
a bit stupid or you back to where you
started again before and you go again
you come up with another idea another
Google doc another Facebook ad another
whatever and the thing is inside we we
think that everybody's watching it I'm
think I'm thinking all my friends all
the nurses at work all of my junior
doctor colleagues are going to be like
huh what a this Ali guy thinking he
can give relationship advice he doesn't
even have a qualification sounds to me
like they're not true friends your true
friends will be like supported my true
friends won't care they'd be like sick
yeah ex I'm thinking about the
colleagues at work yeah well screw them
screw them let let them do you know do
them and this is about building success
for
you